there are creatures in Greek mythology
that possess unrivaled beauty there are
those that install fear with just a
glance and there are those that are so
hideous and gruesome that not even her
own father could bear the sight of them
the creatures that I'm referring to are
the Hecate encrease much like the
Cyclops and the Titans the Hecker
tankers were born from the union of
Uranus and Gaia but unlike their
siblings the hokotan Crees had a
monstrous appearance they were giant
creatures with fifty pairs of hands and
fifty heads they were sometimes referred
to as the hundred handed ones having
fifty heads and fifty pairs of hands
that belonged to different individuals
meant that the Hecate encrease struggled
to control themselves in unison with
endless screams and limbs flailing
uncontrollably they were wild and
incapable of even them a simple action
the birth of the hecatomb Crees caused
guy a great pain and suffering upon
seeing them
Uranus knew that they would never be as
graceful as his previous children and he
refused to name them instead referring
to them as the hundred handed ones Gaia
on the other hand loved all her children
equally and gave them names bry aureus
the vigorous kotas the furious and
Gaia's the big lemoned uranus
unfortunately did not share Gaia's love
and his disdain only grew towards the
hecatomb quarries he hated their
appearance so much that he pushed him
back into the womb of gaia where they
would remain until Uranus was defeated
and exiled in some variations Uranus
instead banished them to the pits of
Tartarus when they were born with no
mother to love or nourish them they did
the only thing they could and fed upon
their own violence and anger becoming
more monstrous with each passing minute
until the day Cronus castrated his
father when the gates of Tartarus swung
open and they were finally free to leave
the hell that they had been imprisoned
in
the hecatomb crease had only known
violence and cruelty their entire lives
and upon seeing Cronus and the other
Titans their first instinct was to
attack after a grueling battle Cronus
knew that he could not control the
hecatomb crease and he managed to place
them one by one back into Tartarus
once again the Hecate inquiries were
sentenced to the fiery pits of Hell
where their anger would eventually begin
to subside as they accepted their fate
that is until they heard a voice calling
to them Zeus and the Olympians were in
the middle of a war between the
remaining Titans and he believed that
the hecatomb quarries in the Cyclops
that were locked away in Tartarus were
the key to victory unlike his father
Zeus had been told how to approach to
Hecate on Crees
brothers I seek your help in battle and
for your services I will set you free
but beforehand you must prove that you
have mastered the use of your limbs as
well as your rage save your rage for the
coming battle I give you three tasks to
prove yourself worthy of your freedom
first you must defeat the dragon who
guards your prison second you must hurl
a boulder from the entrance of your pit
to the highest point of Mount Olympus
declared Zeus point into the heavens and
third you must locate the Cyclops of in
Tartarus and help them to forge mighty
weapons to defeat our father Cronus for
the first time the Hecate encrease will
not treat it like monsters and they
completed Zeus is first to Labour's
eagerly awaiting revenge upon the Titans
during the battle the hecatomb quarries
hold boulders the size of mountains and
the Titans were overwhelmed
Zeus is plan had been successful as the
hecatomb quarries and cyclopses had
handed him victory but the Hecate
encrease had also triumphed over their
own disability and were now in control
of their own bodies
Zeus remained true to his word and he
set them free bry aureus was even
offered Poseidon's daughter's hand in
marriage and was granted a palace
beneath the Aegean Sea he would even
later rescue Zeus from a coup staged by
the other Olympians to overthrow him
kotas and guys became the guardians of
Tartarus as nobody knew the prison
better than they did they were also
given their own palaces under Oceanus
it was often believed that earthquakes
are caused by the many limbs of the
hecatomb crease the story of the
hecatomb crease is one of redemption the
creatures were neglected from birth and
they were treated like monsters until
they eventually became exactly that but
when given the chance and treated as
equals the eckerton curries redeemed
themselves and earned their place
amongst the gods I hope you guys enjoyed
the video if you did as always give it a
like and let me know in the comments
below the support as of late has been
amazing I've received so many new video
requests from you guys and I do note
them all down I have a bunch of videos
that are ready to be released
but they're currently on hold until
YouTube monetizes my channel because at
the moment I earn nothing from YouTube
and it's pretty hard to justify putting
the time in and it's quite de motivating
as well when you do put all that time in
and get nothing back in return so until
I hear back from YouTube I'll try my
best to keep my uploads regular but when
they do actually get back to me
uploads will be a lot more frequent so I
just want to thank everyone for
constantly coming back and watching my
videos and being so patient
I guess as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained